hi I'm Kristen Goodwin on this episode
of the Fox News rundown it was a fiery
Democratic presidential debate on
Wednesday former Obama White House
economic adviser Robert wolf and Ari
Fleischer former White House press
secretary under President George W Bush
joined host Lisa Brady to preview the
upcoming Nevada caucus they'll weigh in
on which contenders need a big day to
stay alive in the race to the White
House and whether a divided Democratic
Party only helps President Trump
Saturday marks the 40th anniversary of
an iconic moment in sports history the
u.s. men's Olympic hockey team defeating
the Soviet Union in the 1980 Winter
Games the team captain Mike Eruzione
joins the rundown to discuss why the
Miracle on Ice still means so much to so
many Americans plus commentary from Fox
News Sunday host Chris Wallace the Fox
News rundown is a Daily News podcast
where we take a deeper look at the
stories important to you you can
subscribe on your favorite podcast
player by going to Fox News podcast.com
i'm shannon bream I'm Tom shaloo I'm
Maria Bartiromo and this is the Fox News
rundown
[Music]
Friday February 21st 2020
I'm Lisa Brady it's Nevada's turn on the
presidential calendar but will the
caucus this weekend answer any questions
for a divided Democratic Party the more
people that enter Super Tuesday with a
chance to get 15% the more probability
is we're going to a contested convention
I'm Dave Anthony do you believe in
miracles
tomorrow is the 40th anniversary of an
iconic moment in sports when the u.s.
upset the Soviets in the Olympics to us
it was a hockey game but to a lot of
people in this country it was more about
we showed the world what we know what
makes this country so great and I'm
Chris Wallace I've got the final word on
the Fox News rundown
most of the Democrats running for
president are now hunkered down in
Nevada fighting for delegates in
Saturday's caucuses the third vote on
the 2020 calendar and it comes just a
few days after a bruising showdown
especially for debate newcomer Mike
Bloomberg Bloomberg isn't on the ballot
in Nevada he held a rally Thursday in
Salt Lake City we may very well be on
the way to nominating somebody who
cannot win in November and if we choose
a candidate who appeals to a small base
like senator Sanders it will be a fatal
error the former New York Mayor sticking
to his strategy of skipping the first
four contests to focus on Super Tuesday
he had been rising in the polls driven
by heavy spending on campaign ads it's
not clear yet how much that could suffer
from Wednesday's debate performance it's
clear that Mayor Bloomberg was
everyone's target Robert wolf is a
former economic adviser to President
Obama now CEO of the advisory firm 32
Advisers and a Fox News contributor
he seemed to be ill-prepared which for
someone that has known the mayor you
know or Mike for over 30 years and was
there with him from Salomon Brothers and
has been with them many times from then
on he's someone that you think
preparation first that's just kind of
how you think of him he's an analytical
guy he's a data guy and he was clearly
frozen on stage the minute you know
Bernie went after him but then Elizabeth
Warren came after him hard on race and
misogyny and everything else it was like
wow and he was it seemed ill-prepared
Warren seemed more like the candidate
who had been surging last fall she just
seemed you know more fire Regan sharper
again but it's hard to know how much a
good debate performance can help it
certainly helped Amy Klobuchar before
the New Hampshire primary but I guess it
remains to be seen what happens Saturday
and Nevada I think Elizabeth Warren it
was an important night for a few
different reasons one my guesses
the the the viewership is gonna be high
because Mayor Bloomberg was the first
time on stage so that's always a good
thing you get the Airways for free
number two she did good fundraising
after she was strong in her numbers
number three she disappointed in Iowa
and New Hampshire versus her
expectations so this gets her back in
the game gets abuzz agai again what
happened in the fall that you mentioned
when she was kind of looked like she was
gonna be the lead candidate she really
struggled to discuss where she was on
Medicare for all and she pivoted
multiple times and she really didn't
wasn't able to hold the lead listen
she's incredibly smart she has a lot of
policies that make sense and I think she
tried to go too far left early on and
wasn't comfortable there and I think
she's probably in a better place where
she is now where she can be someone who
believes she's a capitalist but wants
hard regulatory regime kind of
surrounding it some things haven't
changed though she seemed to get herself
in trouble when she then pivoted and
tried to explain her health care plan in
more detail and people were not happy
with them with the actual numbers and
that that hasn't changed the plan hasn't
changed yeah Lisa you're right I mean
one I am NOT for Medicare for all I'm
for healthcare as a right but I'm for
someone that you can keep your private
insurance but we should extend the
public option so there should be no
uninsured and those were preconditions
should be able to get health care I
think she has struggled with it and that
has been you know that has been in many
ways her biggest issue because health
care is a major topic for everybody and
she kind of goes all over the place on
the flip side you know Bernie Sanders
has not had to explain himself he has
not been able to say how he pays for it
which is why I think Joe Biden actually
when it came to health care I actually
think he was the best and I think that
that's a good sign for him he needs
momentum he needs to come and top three
Nevada he wins needs to win South
Carolina so he has some strength going
in Super Tuesday in Nevada the union
vote can be a big deal and it's
certainly a more diverse electorate than
Iowa and New Hampshire
so does Joe Biden still may
get to South Carolina if he does very
poorly in Nevada I think he's going to
South Carolina no matter where he comes
in Nevada Nevada we always have a debate
how you say it so I'll say Nevada my gut
tells me he's gonna be top three in
Nevada and there's a chance he
outperforms I think either way I don't
think anyone's going to be a north of
30% in Nevada I just don't think it's
gonna happen so I think we're gonna go
back I mean Lisa let's take a step back
Iowa in 2008 Obama was at 40% ed woods
and Clinton were each of 30% in 2016
Hillary and Bernie were each near 50% we
didn't have anyone north of 25% we go to
no hint New Hampshire in 2008 we had
three candidates north of 30% we had two
candidates one in 60 something percent
one at 30 plus percent we had no one at
25% again in New Hampshire for the most
part no one near 30 percent so it's not
like when we talk frontrunner status
it's not as if we're talking about
anyone north of 25 percent we're talking
about six candidates between 10 and 25%
probably good for Mike Bloomberg that
he's not on the ballot in in Nevada and
and Tom Styer another billionaire in the
race is on the ballot but he wasn't on
the debate stage but you know I guess
maybe that gives Bloomberg more time to
try to recover from the debate
performance I mean he hadn't had a
debate in 11 years
to be fair yeah I would respectfully
disagree with that I think that if you
want to be present in the United States
put your hat in the ring and go for it I
think he would have been better off if
he's part of Nevada and South Carolina
because the one reason is he would knock
other people out of big going into Super
Tuesday so the more people that enter
Super Tuesday with a chance to get 15%
the more probability is we're going to a
contested convention you have any gut
feelings at this point about an eventual
nominee I don't I'm a math guy my
background is Wall Street you know I
went to Wharton so I've always been more
analytical and I'm struggling to figure
out how anyone can get the number of
Delegates to be the
nominee if we have a half a dozen people
staying in the race for a very long time
and if I was running a campaign I would
tell those people to stay in the race
and try to collect delegates because you
become an incredible power broker this
summer in Milwaukee by having delegates
and we don't know who the candidates
going to be eventually there will be a
nominee I think this race is going to be
close to November no matter who the
president opponent is Ari Fleischer is
also a Fox News contributor and former
White House press secretary to President
George W Bush I think Bernie is likely
the easiest opponent the president will
have to defeat but whoever the Democrats
put up has a chance of winning the White
House including Bernie and that's
because America is so divided whoever
the Democrat is going to start with 47
48 percent of the vote and that's just
the reality of America today what do you
think of the president's strategy
holding rallies basically on the eve of
the contest the early contests he had a
you know big rally on the eve of the
primary in New Hampshire he's going to
have another one on the eve of this
weekend's caucuses in Nevada I mean he
certainly is not sounding like someone
who's anything less than confident our
poll numbers are higher today
although I guess that could just be the
image that he's trying to project you've
got people waiting for hours and hours
to get into these events with him as you
know his fervent most fervent supporters
have always done is there a danger
though of being overconfident
oh I don't look at this as
overconfidence I look at this as number
one real smart politics and to a whole
lot of fun you know when you're a voter
in the state of New Hampshire or Iowa
should only Democrats get to engage in
politics you know Republicans are
sitting there going we've got our guy
we've got our candidate and they love it
when he shows up so it's good for the
president's team to test their
organizational machinery and delivering
gigantic crowds when people are really
watching and paying attention it's just
a smart electoral thing to do he did run
on draining the swamp though and it
could be argued that several of the
Pardons and commutations announced this
week in addition to some of his other
post impeachment behavior you know
Houston officials that testified against
him during the house hearings this kind
of thing
I don't know could that end up feeling
kind of like swampy behavior to a voter
and say Wisconsin well I don't think
that's the case but Democrats are going
to make but I split that into number one
anybody who works in the White House
whether you're in the National Security
Council or in the main part of the White
House supporting the president if you
don't believe in the president don't
work there they shouldn't work there you
were in service to the president yes you
represent your country but you happen to
be serving the president and so if you
can't support the president go back to
the Pentagon go back to the Department
of Energy go back to the State
Department or wherever it was that you
were detailed from to have the honor of
a temporary service at the White House
or at the NSC on behalf of the president
and if you leak if you don't support the
president you don't belong in the White
House so I have no problem with what the
president did on that front with the
commutations in the pardons I found a
lot of them to be head scratchers and
that's because I'm the law and order guy
and I don't know if 14 years was the
right sentence for the governor of
Illinois or whether there should have
been eight I'm not smart enough to know
what
differences but I do question why a
president would spend his time kind of
figure that out and let a man out of
prison who sold the senousy do you think
it's a liability for the president in
this election though you know doing
things like tweeting about the Roger
stone case or is that already baked into
the cake of how people see him at this
point after three years in office I
think that's a good point it's baked
into the cake but that is a slice of the
cake that I've never liked and I speak
out against there's so many good policy
things the president has done but
sometimes temperamentally and via
Twitter the president goes too far
and one instance Reid has gone too far
is weighing in from the White House on
an individual or any individual criminal
case and the problem with that and this
is why I objected when Barack Obama did
it about Hillary Clinton and why ejected
when Barack Obama did it about the IRS
investigation of conservatives he
dismissed Obama did both of those it was
wrong with the President to speak out on
a criminal justice matter because White
House's inherently politicized what has
to be a process where justice is blind
presidents should not weigh in any
reflections from a Republican point of
view looking at the caucuses in Nevada
this weekend any predictions and what
will happen with the Democrats well I
think you've got to say Bernie still is
looking good you know Bernie is really
changing the Democratic Party just as
president Trump changed the Republican
Party and Bernie is bringing this
enthusiasm this energy for the wacky
principles that he represents and he
represents those principles with
authentic fashion he is a socialist he
believes in it he believes from the
confiscation of wealth he believes that
nationalized in the health care industry
he believes in the government dictating
what can and cannot be done for energy
development it's atrocious
but it's principled and what we're
really seeing is a Democratic Party
that's changing before our very eyes
where socialism is now a real live
possibility and attraction for them you
know at what President Trump was making
all the news and all the noise what's
gotten lost that's even more important
is the lurch leftward inside the
Democratic Party according to Gallup
when Bill Clinton was president only
25% of Democrats self-identified as
liberal today it is 51% call themselves
liberal in one generation the Liberals
have taken over there already liberal
party and that's what we're seeing now
with Bernie and that's why we'll not be
surprised if Bernie wins Nevada and
certainly Wednesday's debate helped
Bernie
Mike Bloomberg bombed all the other
Democrats fought squat and split and
that just keeps Bernie an elevated
plurality status ari fleischer former
White House press secretary for
President George W Bush also a Fox News
contributor thanks as always for your
time thank you Lisa good to be with you
this is Chris Wallace with your Fox News
commentary
coming up there have been a lot of big
games and achievements in sports but
what happened 40 years ago Saturday may
top them all Sports Illustrated called
it the greatest sports moment of the
20th century
[Applause]
now is Al Michaels famous call on ABC
Sports as Team USA pulled off a huge
Olympic upset beating the Soviet Union
four to three in front of American fans
going crazy in the Lake Placid New York
and it's hard to believe in this digital
day and age it's a game that wasn't even
on live TV it aired on tape delay but
the whole country celebrated even people
who could care less about hockey we beat
our arch rivals the Soviets a team many
considered unbeatable in the middle of
the Cold War it's it's amazing you know
you kind of look back on it and realize
it was 40 years ago and sometimes it
feels like it was yesterday
Mike Eruzione was the 1980 US team
captain and scored would ended up the
game-winning goal in the third period
it's 40 years and my teammates and I are
still around and excited about you know
the anniversary and the celebration yeah
big gathering you're gonna have together
right yeah we're gonna be in Las Vegas
the Vegas Knights are bringing the team
out there for a weekend is this the
biggest group you've had together in a
long time this is the biggest we've had
probably since 2002 when we lit the
cauldron in Salt Lake City so yeah this
would be the biggest of everyone at the
same time you know we get 10 guys 12
guys 14 guys but never never eight this
will be a case of 18 that's oh that's a
really nice gathering I'm sure you're
looking forward yes I'm sure it's gonna
be a lot of fun now when you went back
in 2002 and it was there you know the
games in the US what's it like to be in
that moment when you light the cauldron
that's the start of the Olympics yeah I
think probably the ultimate honor you
can give an Olympic athlete or in our
case an Olympic team
Muhammad Ali did in Atlanta Rafer
Johnson in Los Angeles and they selected
us I remember Mitt Romney called me well
in advance saying look at hold up cold
the night of the opening ceremonies
you're gonna be a part of the the you
know the the event and didn't know the
whole team was gonna be there till a few
days before they decided to bring the
whole team in to do it and and that was
just you know it was an unbelievable
proud moment this was right after 9/11
this was a very emotional that they
brought the flag in from the World Trade
Center it was a very emotional opening
ceremonies and I I remember sitting back
and
the whole format's gonna be Picabo
Street and Cammi Granato we're gonna
bring the torch up the stairs can we
great women's hockey player and right
Picabo great skier and mica they get to
the top you go out get the torch hold it
up then call your teammates they're
gonna come from behind the curtain I
said I can do this this isn't my heart's
pumping like you this is unbelievable
this is gonna happen just before I go
out to pack get the torch Mark Johnson
one of my teammates taps me on the
shoulder and he says remember four
billion people are watching he said
don't drop the torch I said I said no he
can do this and we did it and it was it
was incredible
you scored one of the most iconic goals
in the history of hockey one of the most
important moments in the history of
sports how do you get sick of talking
about it no I I don't think about it
that way either I just I look at it as I
didn't had an opportunity to help our
team and I scored a goal and we ended up
winning 4-3 players always talked like
well it was if you know if Mark Johnson
doesn't score with one second left to go
in the first period how that one Billy
Baker doesn't score against Sweden and
we lose that game you know what happens
after that so things happen throughout
the games the word they use now is in
make plays you know teams who win
championships make plays and I think
that's what happened for us in 1980 and
I was fortunate to to make a play and
you know looking back on it it's kind of
cool to know that you know I had the
winning goal against the Soviets but you
know other things happen for us to get
to that point it's always ever since Al
Michaels do you believe in miracles
right it's the miracle the miracle does
that it all bother you considering it a
miracle because you guys believed you
could win so it wasn't you couldn't have
thought it's a miracle you know cat
miracle is a catchy phrase and and it
sounds nice but it you know wasn't a
miracle it wasn't a fluke we weren't
lucky Craig Patrick our assistant coach
after the Olympics said it best he said
they deserve what they got you know we
deserve to win that tournament and we
did it's funny I play golf with out once
in a while loading some of the celebrity
tournaments and we're together and we're
walking up a fairway and sooner or later
someone's gonna yell do you believe in
miracles yes or I'll be walking through
an airport and say hey Mike do you
believe in miracles and I'm like so
maybe that one
but no you know it was you know the
miracles happened in much more dramatic
fashion and
than a hockey game so uh it was it was
great and and and a moment that my
teammates and I uh very proud to have
been a part of bring us back I know you
talk about it all the time and bring us
back to that moment you guys it's now
tied what is about ten minutes or so
yeah Mark Johnson scored a power play
goal to make it 3-3 and then I got on
the ice on a buzzy Schneider to dump the
puck in the zone my line was up next so
I jumped over the boards and John
Harrington went in the corner fought the
Soviet for the puck kind of chipped it
by the Soviet player Mark Pavlik pav got
there at the same time with two Soviet
players and he was able to chip it to me
coming across the blue line and I picked
the puck up and it was a defenseman in
front of me and I thought if he stays
I'm gonna use him as a screen he stayed
and I had the whole far corner and if
anything I pulled it just a little cuz I
was going across my body but got enough
of it and found the opening and gave us
the lead when the puck goes in what's in
your mind at that moment we've have the
lead yeah I was four to three and ten
minutes left to go and against the
Soviets that ten minutes against that
team you know they can score five goals
in ten minutes easily and they've been
averaging eight nine goals a game so
this made this goal for two three so we
we just needed to continue to play the
way we had been playing and-and-and we
did in the last ten minutes of the game
I think the Soviets had me six shots on
goal and three of them were from outside
of the blue line when they were in the
middle of this game did you sense their
frustration I think we sensed it after I
made it 4-3 because they started doing
things that were uncharacteristic like
dump the puck in his own they never did
things like that the fact that they
never pulled the goalie at the end was
kind of shocking and maybe looking back
they'd never been behind before so maybe
that's why there were an unusual
position so they they did a lot of
things that were again uncharacteristic
of them
you guys are celebrating you you score
you win the game you're on American ice
you're having a that's going haywire
over there did you ever look over and
see that them just standing there
looking at this when I was walking
through skating through the line shaking
hands it was almost like a disbelief on
their face like what what just happened
I think they were there was stunned you
know they'd never lost they hadn't lost
in 40 40 consecutive games
in Olympics and this was this was their
fourth possible gold medal in the last
few epic years so yeah I think they were
they were real happy 1980 was not the
first time the US men's hockey team won
a gold medal the Americans also came out
on top in the 1960 Winter Olympics and
they also did it on us ice at the games
in Valley in California back on
this day February 21st 60 years ago they
battered Australia 12 to 1 it was their
second of 7 wins in an undefeated
Olympics but that gold medal isn't as
revered as Mike Eruzione 's 1980 squad
tension with the Soviet Union had gotten
even greater and two days before the US
beat the Soviet Union in 1980 a us
deadline expired for Soviet troops to
pull out of Afghanistan following the
Soviets 1979 invasion and then soon
after that led the u.s. to boycott the
1980 Summer Olympics in Moscow and the
Soviets retaliated boycotting the 1984
Summer Games in Los Angeles to us it was
a hockey game but to a lot of people in
this country it was more about we showed
the world you know what makes this
country so great you know underdogs and
and hard working kids and came from
working class families who went out and
did something and shocked the world and
I think you know the political climate
as you mentioned the hostages have been
taken the Soviets threat of a cold war
the Soviets have been made in
Afghanistan gas lines inflation you know
President Carter gave us big speak up
speech about how this country has kind
of lost its malaise right yeah so will
you people we're looking for a good
story and feel-good something and it
happened to be us and of all sports ice
hockey but this of course yeah not the
most American sport right but still a
big moment and that's not the end of the
story doesn't end you don't get your
gold medals after you play the Soviets
you still have to play Finland to win
the gold if we people didn't know if we
lost our tide Sunday we could have come
in fourth place and not even won a medal
so as great as a Soviet victory was you
know we didn't go to the Olympics to win
one game we went that with the hope and
dream of winning the whole thing
now we had that opportunity we had the
opportunity to play well and and and
finish finish the job now now how does a
team coming off one of the biggest
history sports upsets in history prepare
for the next one
Saturday's practice might have been the
hardest practice we had all year
I remember going in the locker room and
the guys were laughing and joking we
were signing sticks and pictures and
herb came in and just flipped out Oh
screaming and yelling who do you guys
think you are and I'm like why is he so
pissed off we just beat the Soviets you
know have us a good we're here to
celebrate a huddle but what he did he
brought us right back down to earth by
skating us that morning we skated hard
and he just got that energy out of us
and I know we were ready to play Sunday
matter of fact after we beat Finland if
there was another game to play we would
have been ready I mean that's just the
type of team team that we had players
that just loved to play hockey but herb
got that energy out of us and had us
ready to go on Sunday I remember as a
nine-year-old kid hockey player in
Connecticut watching the Finland game on
that Sunday that was not an easy game
either no we know we were trailing again
trailing every game we were trailing
every Olympic game but against Romania
so yeah wit wit were trailing 2 to 1
going into the third period and I
remember that locker room like it was
yesterday the Atmos Jack O'Callahan must
have said it a hundred times there's no
way a bunch of fins are keeping us from
a gold medal and the energy was
incredible and herb walked in the locker
room and that's when he made that famous
speech he pointed his finger and I said
if you lose this game you'll take it to
your grave then he walked out he stopped
at the door he pointed his finger back
at us and he said your grave and walked
out and of course there were a couple of
words and running a grave but he was
right you know we too come so far to
work so hard to accomplish so much to
let it slip away would have stayed with
us forever and we went out in my opinion
played the best the best 20 minutes of
hockey we played all during the Olympics
was that third period against Finland we
scored three goals we won four to two
and we win the whole thing everybody
remembers Jim crying your goalie you
know looking for his dad just put the
flag the flag yeah I mean that's that's
it's it's a it's an amazing moment and
to watch that I you know I still have
vivid memories of it all now it's a
happy ending like a storybook ending
there have been movies I think you
helped make the first walk right
what do you think of miracle the one
people know the most I thought it was
done well you know Kurt Russell was
brilliant he was good as herb and
although when the movie herb was a
little friendlier Hurd was a little more
intense
so the real Herb Brooks didn't quite was
was harsher than the one in the movie oh
yeah it wasn't even close yeah there's a
scene in the movie where Kurt smiles I
don't ever remember her smiling but I
thought the movie was well done you know
there was some Hollywood ish scenes here
and there but for the most part they got
the story right as far as we won now you
wrote a book about it the makings of a
miracle the untold story of the captain
of the 1980 gold medal winning the US
Olympic hockey team why did it take so
long well the dead who helped help write
it with me approached me a couple years
ago about writing a book about the 80
team you know 40 years later and I
talked to my teammates and a bunch of
them said no I'm not interested so Neil
said what about you why don't I want to
write a book and I want to write a book
you score the big goal so I thought
about it and I said you know what let's
do it and the reason I wrote it and it's
in it's in the book is I wanted my
grandkids to know the puppet did more
than play two weeks in Lake Placid Mike
Eruzione big goal score and the win over
the Soviets congratulations on the book
and thanks for joining us thank you
thank you for your help with the book as
well
[Music]
from the Fox News podcasts Network
download and listen to the media buzz
meter with Howard Kurtz how he picks
five stories most important to the most
entertaining to the buzziest subscribe
and listen now by going to fox news
podcast calm America is listening to Fox
News some good news with Tonya J powers
man's best friend has a special place in
our hearts
dogs are there for us they're happy to
see us when we walk in the door and they
come in all shapes sizes and
temperaments there are dancing dogs like
Snoopy
[Music]
there are dogs that are there for you
when people let you down
[Music]
there are escaping dogs and then there's
Persie he's a two-year-old kakapo who
lives in Toronto and he plays games
no not like fetch real games Percy is
the star of an Instagram video that
shows him playing a round of the Hasbro
game Kinect for with his owner Sarah
Shapiro Ward who was also a dog trainer
[Music]
he picks the red piece gets a little
treat between pieces
she's the yellow piece he's the red
piece and there are a couple of blocks
in there where she doesn't get to go
forward Sarah says it's impressive that
Percy's picked up the gist of the game
he's not great with a strategy of
winning just yet but he likes to play
and she cheers him on you can follow his
adventures on instagram at prancing
underscore percy tonya j powers fox news
[Music]
it's time for your Fox News commentary
what's on your mind
hi I'm Chris Wallace anchor of Fox News
Sunday and one of the big stories this
week will be that really interesting
debate in Nevada on Wednesday night
these guys just really went after each
other first of all and not so happy
welcome to Mayor Bloomberg to the debate
stage and then it was very interesting
to watch some of the things you could
see people judge really go after him at
Klobuchar because he they can't have
these two Midwestern centrists and
they're one that one is trying to knock
the other out the big winner to me was
was Bernie Sanders it seemed to me he
did pretty darn well he you know has
been saying the same things and we're
attacking Michael Bloomberg for the
first time has a lot of residents call
him Bernie Sanders a socialist for the
400th time doesn't and and you know they
I understand the desire to go after
Bloomberg because of all the money he's
made and you know the argument that he
bought his way into the debate stage but
you don't do something to try to stop
the Bernie train he's gonna have an
insurmountable lead in the delegates
after Super Tuesday and this thing could
be in effect over so Bernie Sanders is
at this point I mean if you had to bet I
think you would have to bet that he's
going to be the nominee of the
Democratic Party things could change
Lord knows but you wouldn't trade
positions for anybody else at this point
we'll be talking about all about on Fox
News Sunday
you have been listening to the FoxNews
rundown stay up to date by subscribing
the Fox News radios hourly newscast at
FoxNews podcasts dot-com and for
up-to-the-minute news visit Fox news.com
[Music]
with Greg Gutfeld Jenifer Hamma we rode
all the songs together but then he
peaced out didn't want anything to do
with the mixing right subscribed and
listen now by going to a Fox News
podcasts dot-com